another one bites the dust
not just hipster rasputin jack dorsey at
twitter who stepped down apparently
voluntarily or somewhat voluntarily
fredo
fredo cuomo at cnn
was taken out into a fishing boat on the
lake
and he didn't come back metaphorically
speaking
he has been suspended indefinitely from
cnn after a story came out that fredo
advised his brother andrew cuomo who was
you know governor of new york during his
political scandals and cuomo may chris
cuomo may have used some of his
journalistic contacts to try to help
cuomo here's the statement from cnn
when chris admitted to us that he had
offered advice to his brother's staff he
broke our rules and we acknowledged that
publicly hold on i just want to pause
right there the way that cnn phrased
this
makes it seem like the transgression was
not the wrong doing it wasn't that he
helped his brother and used his contacts
it's that he admitted the wrong doing
right he says when chris admitted to us
that he did this he broke our rules
you're never at cnn the rule is you
never admit wrongdoing so he was that a
freudian slip was that a freightoen slip
i think it might have been they go on we
also appreciated the unique position he
was in and understood his need to put
family first however these documents
point to a greater level of involvement
in his brother's efforts than we
previously knew as a result we have
suspended chris
indefinitely pending further evaluation
this is going to be
maybe an unpopular view on the right but
i've got to say it because it's my view
and i think we ought to put the truth
first
i feel bad for fredo
i feel bad for freda
not because he didn't do anything wrong
he did a lot of things wrong
but i think he's being held to a
different standard here than other cnn
employees this cyber week bowlin branch
is offering their greatest deal of the
entire year if last night's sleep was
not incredible if you woke up you just
thought i need something a little better
bowling branches sheets will make all
the difference with mullen branch you
get the best sleep of your life with
their highest quality organic cotton
sheets bowlin branch holds themselves to
high standards across the board not just
their sheets that are made this way
their pillows their bath towels their
robes are too the signature hemmed
sheets are their all-time best seller i
have
gotten multiple
hem sheets i have bought them you know
sometimes i get freebies i have bought
them they are that good
in my life i have had the privilege on
occasion of sleeping in a really nice
hotel you know if i'm on the road or to
give a speech or something like that or
when i can steal the credit card from
shapiro and the big difference with nice
hotels
is it's the bedding it's the sheets with
bowlin branch you can sleep on a
five-star hotel kind of bedding every
single night this cyber week give your
loved ones the best sleep of their lives
or treat yourself with bowl and branch
the christmas packaging famously soft
sheets blankets pillows and more will
make a difference that everyone will
feel get 25 off from november 23rd
through december 2nd with their best
offer of the year at bowlingbranch.com
get 25 off b-o-l-l and branch dot com
exclusions may apply first of all is
this the story here the shocking the big
revelation
is that a cnn host a cnn employee
whose brother and father were both
democrat governors of new york
might just possibly be a democrat
operative
no you're stop the presses you're
kidding me what gosh next you're going
to tell me that that bridge that i
bought in brooklyn isn't really mine is
that really you're telling me he is a
democrat
no way
second of all
he's not the first
cnn employee or
establishment media employee to do this
remember donna brazile donna brazile
i think while working for cnn passed
debate questions to hillary clinton she
still works throughout the establishment
media remember uh candy crowley remember
her she was moderating a debate between
barack obama and mitt romney and she
just lied on behalf of barack obama to
trip up romney made him lose the debate
based on a complete lie
regarding the benghazi terror attack
remember that
doesn't matter
oopsie daisy whoops moves on
they're they're all democrat operatives
that's what cnn is
cnn is not some impartial
journalistic outlet where facts matter
first no matter what they say it's a
propaganda piece for the left
i don't even really it doesn't even
really bother me in the history of media
generally parties have had their own
outlets the republicans had their
outlets the democrats had their outlet
that's why their newspaper is called the
tennessee democrat right you know and so
i don't i don't really
even mind that i wish they were more
honest about it but
poor fredo
poor fredo
i guess that was ever thus
four fredo's he's getting frustrated
he's saying i'm smart
not like everybody says like dumb i'm
smart i can do things
but he can't now because he's been
suspended poor guy all right you know do
you remember i don't mean to be labor
the point on chris chris cuomo but do
you remember during kovid
he got kovid and then he pretended that
he was
he was holding up and quarantining in
his basement
and then he even did that whole thing
where
they filmed him coming up for the first
time and seeing his family and i missed
you and then it was all fake because it
turned out that he was actually going
out for bike rides with his family
during the alleged quarantine out in the
hamptons and the only reason we know
that is because he got into a fight with
some guy on the street and the guy said
hey oh aren't you supposed to be holed
up in your room and he's getting they
get into a big fight and shouting match
so it's all bs the guy spreads lies on
his show constantly that though doesn't
violate the journalistic integrity of
cnn
what violates the journalistic integrity
seriously is that he got caught
that's what does it i'm glad you like
that clip now i need you to ring the
bell
i need it
i need it i don't ask for very much do i
no i don't
just got to ring that bell you get the
notifications if you don't get the
notifications because of our friends at
big tech
then maybe head on over to apple podcast
spotify stitch or google play wherever
you get your audio podcasts subscribe
maybe leave a five star review
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you